hey guys we just finished up filming the
podcast i'm just going to let you know
i'm throwing this in right in the
beginning subscribe to the podcast we
have like 80 of the people that watch
this are not subscribed so subscribe to
the podcast thank you so much and enjoy
the episode what's up guys welcome back
to the iced coffee episode
this is good hey we could just leave it
yeah yeah we're good so this is the 28th
ever 18 600 i'm carter sharer you guys
are watching the iced coffee
well you know what we've had a few
guests though it's a late hour i think
too only two out of like probably 20
guests have actually got it really on
the first try the first try was really
close i didn't know you wanted that ever
we have a format that works here and the
28th ever episode is part of it yeah
okay so that was very important very
important but we did fine we did fine
but welcome to the iced coffee hour this
is really exciting all right you're on
youtube for those that don't know uh
your main channel has what seven eight
is it eight million subscribers now
seven million it's seven something yeah
not eight yet almost eight million
subscribers uh you have a few channels
then you as well so you do what would
you what would you categorize your main
channel as like the type of content yeah
they make
uh like viral content based on like
youtube so we make content for uh
younger demographics so like kids
basically like high school and younger
we do challenges we do pranks we do
social experiments and i'm getting a lot
more into like building crazy stuff like
building the giant 28 foot lego yacht
and then trying to float in my pool so
just totally ran like every episode is
just so different we did like last to
leave lion cage and we did it for real
we were in there for four hours with a
real full-grown lion
what that line was tamed correct it was
a very same line it says the only line
in the country you could ever do this
with it's still frightening yeah it was
crazy it's so big
really quick how is this one so tame
yeah because the owner found it as a cub
and she raises them from and like
handles them every single day that's how
you would like tame a large cat and
there's something special about this one
and so this one appears in a lot of
different movies as like a lion um
and uh so it's like four years old and
like this one's just as they say a very
special line did you feel safe in there
yeah until like something had happened
and then it's like then you realize
there's no way you're getting out in
time if something were to happen like it
would get up and you realize the size or
you just reach like it reaches its paw
you just realize how fast and his paws
are like this big
like they were the size of your face i
mean it was really wild did you have
like safety measures
not really no paramedics on site or
anything like that um you know we had
the uh the owner in there that was one
thing she had to be in the cage with us
at all times and if she wasn't there
then it would be a different vibe i
think for the line okay say the cage is
a square were you just in the exact
opposite side of like the well the line
yes and then i mean you could leave any
time the gate wasn't locked but it was
you know if you open the latch and just
walk out but if you leave you lose as
last to leave wins
uh but then we did challenges as it
progressed you had to go up and like
touch the line
isn't that just provoking it
it's just it's like you play until you
have to pull the lion's tail afterwards
yeah yeah you have to anchor the line
then we
yeah that was the last challenge did you
win
uh no i did not win it was scary
yeah no it was it's terrifying the teeth
like everything about it was uh pretty
wild how much does that cost we paid i
think like 4 500 bucks
so it's a little bit overwhelming for a
day to run a line for a day it took us
like four hours and the hot sun was very
hot that day
uh to film
and i think the check was like 45 wow
100 something like that but how do you
one-up that because i've seen a lot of
your videos it kind of builds on one
another like you can't go down like once
once you do a lion you can't go and do
like a chimpanzee you gotta do like now
a bear
or an alligator or something more
vicious so in the actual video uh to
determine one of the winners at the end
since we all like left kind of like at
the around like the four hour mark we
did like a tie breaker around with a
grizzly bear and that thing was even
bigger and very aggressive so it was
through the cage and the it was actually
one of the owner's ideas like get some
of this like fruit and put it on your
cheek and then put your cheek up against
the fence and he'll lick it no so we're
doing that right so i'm kind of doing it
scary i mean this thing is going fast so
now i was standing ready getting ready
for the cameras and he reaches under and
almost grabs my shoe to try to pull me
under
and they so the ladies like go step out
and i got stuff down you almost grabbed
me and pulled me into the fence
and so i asked her i was like what's he
trying to do like what if you open that
gate says if you open that gate or you
go in that cage he will kill you
immediately that's what he's trying to
do and i'm like so why are you
suggesting to let it lick our faces
it was the whole thing who ensures this
do you do you check with an insurance
company beforehand yeah because this is
a special thing it's like if i were
kaiser i'd say no you put yourself in
danger you put yourself
in a tiger alliance cage we're not going
to cover that
you must have some sort of special
insurance like athletes have this
insurance like stunt people have this
insurance like right
uh we're working on it yeah it's a
process it's a process
uh we so we did try to do this one where
we were gonna jump off the roof into
like a big crash pad we thought that
would be fun for a video and we could
not get insurance for that we talked to
a few places and they were saying no
just like we don't ensure that kind of
stuff but you get insurance for all of
the stunts that you do
they're working on it yeah i mean most
of it is my own personal harm it's very
rarely
um are there like big risks for other
people and we have general liability
insurance for you know someone tripping
at the house or whatever like that but
that one was a very special occasion uh
to like invite my friends into the lion
kids normally it's just like myself and
i'm not gonna sue myself but having
insurance for myself would be good you
know what i mean but um no that's
definitely a frontier that we're
continuing to expand to is like
being smarter with like insurance and
safety and having like paramedics on
site and things like that so you intend
to keep
like pushing the limits here with with
some of the videos because they have
paramedics on sites for for videos made
for like high school and under is that
necessary
to go crazy to go to go that crazy well
it's not that like i feel like i need to
to get views yeah um i just really
wanted to do that video and everyone
else was so down like i wasn't like
begging anyone to do it it was very
willing it was very everyone was very
excited for it and everything
so
uh i mean there are some other videos i
think i got into i felt like i needed to
go big to
you know get views but it's really not
about that it's also not really about
one-upping it's just about making just
interesting entertaining content yeah
really would you would you do the bear
licking the face
yeah you would do it
i would i would i would probably do that
yeah i think that's just like a once in
a lifetime opportunity you know and if
something bad happens something bad
happens but like dying in that way would
be kind of like not cool but like i
think risk of death is low but i think
risk of like getting like you don't want
to be mutilated yeah do some sort of
cost benefit analysis you know obviously
the cost is very high in the event
something happens but at the same time
it's like very low chance so i would
probably the story you would get from
that yeah i mean you would you do that
i don't think it would i just i
don't think i would yeah honestly it's
probably because just because it's a
once in a lifetime opportunity doesn't
mean you need to put yourself at risk
but there's a 100 chance so yeah i mean
if there's a one in 100 chance i'd
rather just not do it i'd rather just
play it safe
yeah i mean playing it safe would be to
not do it i mean like to give to take a
step back okay the whole holistic thing
like we did approach is very like we're
not like stupid jumping into this thing
like we thought about it we talked with
people and all that kind of stuff and we
proceeded with caution we made sure like
even like
uh like i said we like one of the
challenges was to feed it raw chicken
like raw meat like like you know feet
like a hand feed it water in the cage
with this lion sounds crazy why would
you like put bait in the water with
sharks well we asked the lady like all
these things and she says i'm not gonna
increase the risk like just because
you're feeding it like like we made sure
like walk through all the steps but of
course there is you know general risk
and we don't do animals often we do like
little puppies
you know that's my level yeah we don't i
don't know if i would do it again that
video was crazy you know um so i'm not
like big into like
wild animals because you know very
unpredictable so you tend to go for the
virality aspect like what other stuff
do you think is worth mentioning like
what's what's the what would you say is
a craziest video you've done
the craziest video
i don't know what would you say is the
hardest to organize video like the the
most difficult to to get put together to
i don't know just set this to coordinate
right because you did like the lego
video where you where you created like a
whole lego ship and put it in your pool
yeah that one took a little bit of like
logistical planning but big logistics
um we've done stuff with like rental
cars we had like multiple lambos and we
were driving those around
we did
uh i ordered 10 000 rubber chickens from
china and then got those delivered and i
filled like a swimming pool four of them
we like jump into them and like swim and
stuff what do you do with those
afterwards like where did they all go
yeah we gave those away okay so we gave
them away for free on our uh our website
which was really cool a lot of the fan
they sold out like day of is it they
have to pay for shipping they cover the
cost of shipping okay
um which was like three bucks or
something you know but then you get like
this rubber chicken which is probably 15
bucks on amazon or yeah who comes up
with that who who came up with that idea
i think it was probably either me or
phil we were probably hanging out and so
phil if you guys don't know also shout
out to phil he loves uh watching all
your content how cool um he runs our
merchandising and tmr.com and so he has
like a whole supply chain from china
that manufactures custom like
uh apparel hats uh like this hat for
example and then ships them
into uh
la and then we distribute it from there
speaking of which we're gonna turn off
the cameras for a second we'll come
right back on one sec jack i got a
surprise for you
to wear for this i think oh yeah this is
awesome this one's the uh the large one
all right guys i have the uh team rar
hoodie on right now i just gotta say
very very cozy i think that it is very
comfortable this has got to come down
and uh you squeezed into it yeah i think
you're probably normally like medium or
large yeah medium or large definitely
there we go
i don't know if that's gonna look
interesting just to have a weird angle
like that what do you think
mean it would probably need better
lighting like from the side oh well you
know it'll be all mysterious let's just
try it all right so the review of the
hoodie it's actually one of i will say
it is one of the most comfortable
hoodies that i've ever worn it is so
soft on the inside it is incredibly soft
it fits you perfectly really yeah it
does i mean yeah i'm sure if i could fit
yeah stood up because my torso is kind
of and i think if you find this it'd be
like up to here all my height is in my
torso so i know i think you're fine
thanks graham okay it looks good you got
the green one yeah i like the green yeah
i like the bright colors now so we got
to get an understanding of what exactly
team rawr is okay okay how did what does
that stand for how did you
get the idea to make something like that
and also hopefully go into a little bit
of your backstory because i watched a
video today on you i honestly i'm gonna
be honest i haven't seen a lot of your
content i've heard of you and i've seen
you on like you know trending or
whatever plenty of times but i watched
this video where it was like 10 years of
your life yeah that was a good video and
uh you actually really surprised me like
in those 10 years it's not what i
expected you're very
you're very very smart and not that i
wasn't expecting that i was not that i
wasn't that's something that yeah i
wouldn't expect it either for someone to
hang in a lion's cage
like all the all the robotic stuff and
like mechanics and stuff like that
you're very good with all that and you
like went to and studied like physics
and stuff like that and then changed out
to like computer science or whatever
yeah so first off let's get on to the
the team raw how did you come to or we
can go chronologically let's go
chronology yeah yeah
yeah so i was born i mean i don't go
that far
so yeah i went to carnegie mellon
university after high school uh and i
went in to study physics so i was going
to be a physics major freshman year uh
and then i got all the way to like
quantum mechanics and i just thought at
that point it's just like too much it's
just too crazy i can't imagine like if
i'm only here i guess it was sophomore
year taking quantum mechanics the math
is just insane super fascinating stuff i
still love physics so after quantum i
was like you know what like i can't
imagine what i'm going to do for a
living
if this is sophomore year what do i do
after senior year like it's going to be
so deep so uh i did a career change
and then i started getting more
interested in discovering that carnegie
mellon is really good at computer
science and robotics it's like number
one in the country for those kind of
things which is awesome because i've
always been fascinated with robots
and throughout high school you know i
got into legged locomotion which are
like
mechanical linkage systems that like you
turn rotary cranks into like legs
that'll walk across the ground and you
can like have self-propelled things it's
really tough to
describe you'd have to see it sure so
i guess i'm kind of going backwards but
i can throw some uh b-rollers here yeah
from the 10-year like i built like a
12-legged essentially wheelchair that
has legs instead of wheels and they like
walk across the ground and they're
hand-powered i've built
uh
full-size mechanical horses that you can
ride like bicycles
and like you literally climb up it's
like tall
so yeah so i got in you know so uh
throughout school studied uh just took
all the classes i could with robotics
and computer science and kind of picked
and choose the stuff i wanted to learn
and so i actually ended up creating my
own self-defined major and then after
that uh i went to upenn
and we did an incubator program with my
friend phil he was the guy who does uh
the teamrodder.com merchandising
and then while i was there i was doing
self-driving cars and working in the
embedded embedded systems laboratory
doing like micro controllers and sensors
and developing uh like software and
hardware for self-driving cars and then
that's when i got into youtube
how there's no connection there there is
no connection there i mean a little bit
in a sense like
i started discovering like there's more
than just pewdiepie that's like a
professional youtuber
um i never really thought about like
always watch youtube growing up and so
as we started getting into it
uh posting videos and i mean i guess
initially was just kind of the research
i just switched my focus of like trying
to like figure out how to make a car
drive itself let's just figure out how
to post a video that gets views and
there's an algorithm involved there's
audience so i just started doing
research on that and kind of reverse
engineered how to make a video that
somebody would watch and that youtube
would promote
um you know there has to be the right
thumbnail the right title the right
packaging the right upload time the red
upload date the right upload frequency
the right way you create your contact
their content and the way you like speak
into a camera and so i just started
working on all those skills just video
by video
and then went viral like a few months
later didn't even make it six months
into that first job had to find a sublet
sublease for that uh apartment that i
had
and then i moved into my parents house
and then uh
you know three years later now i'm in
bel air what's what does that first
video make how much were you making back
then to be like i'm gonna quit my job
and just
move in with parents and and do youtube
like the first video that actually did
something yes it's all the ones that
made no money at all um
i remember early on we had and this was
me and my brother working together on
this first channel
we hit like i was only making like 12 an
hour as a research assistant
uh love the job was still learning so
much
but that was like kind of my reference
point it's like you know 12 50. um
we did like three grand in a month which
was like a non-zero number i think it
was the first like non-zero like 200
bucks doesn't mean anything to me right
but we made like three grand i was like
wow three grand is like that's like a
real chunk of money like that's
something like let's keep trying this
like let's keep going maybe uh i think
that was the point i was like all right
i'll come home every weekend
to make content and we'll just grind we
did like 14 hour days and we try to make
enough content in two days and edit the
videos so we could post throughout the
week for my next weekend to come home
um and then we had a couple videos that
like hit a million or did well or
something
and then i remember we hit like 20 grand
in one month and i'm like whoa 20 grand
about about two people still 10 grand
which is still more
it's way more than i'm making now and
it's also more than my dream job in
silicon valley which will pay like 114
or something like that
so i'm like wow and we're just getting
started also we have
10k subs i know you could do 100k subs
you can also do a million subs you can
do 10 the amount of growth ahead of us
is tremendous and we're already making
like a a decent amount like
and so i remember having to like talk
with my professor like yo like i know
you just hired me but i want to quit and
so i showed him like that he's like dude
that's just a glitch like that's noise
like it's not gonna happen i'm like dude
no i believe like we can keep this going
up
and uh
so i quit and then we just went full
force that's so smart i hate when people
say that lingo you know no you don't
know you you stick with this
yeah you go to have you talked to the
professor since then
uh
not really i think like a couple months
later before i
moved out to california
he like reached out because i needed to
like bring someone up to speed that was
taking my spot to like run a lab or like
figure out some questions about the code
that i wrote for i made like a
self-balancing robot lab for this grad
program they're like trying out trying
to figure it out so it's like that but
it wasn't like checking and like oh man
i doubted you never any of that never
any like closure like that it was always
just like
he actually told me this
when i was sitting in his office so
nervous because i was so thankful for
the opportunity
and i'm learning a tremendous amount
um but he said something after i tried
quitting well one he said why don't you
try going part time like no full time
like i need to hit this hard he goes
like wow i'm disappointed like you're
you're meant for so much greater
you know you're meant for so much than
playing on photoshop and making you know
nerf videos or whatever do you like
nerdfighteria
that would i mean it's a little bit like
rude but also
like i get what you're saying like
you're meant for so much more you're
going to develop like the cure for
cancer or like something like you're
going to make the like tesla's drive
yourself driving cars you're going to be
the head of a you know i.t or i don't
know like something big yeah is what it
was kind of meaning by it as opposed to
like this is silly like you're meant for
more but i knew what i was doing that he
didn't understand was so much more
you know what i mean like i knew where i
could take it or i believed yeah it
could be something huge i would love
freda to have a follow-up with him yeah
film it yeah film it on the channel i
think that would be such great content
to come full circle and come back invite
him over to your place in bel air
you got you got this mansion man it's
insane this this house has more bedrooms
than i could count
it's mad we'll talk about that soon but
i think that would be so much fun you
bring them by and you give them a give
them a drive in the lamborghini
yeah pick them up from the airport in
the aventador yeah you should do that
give them give them the full stay let
them stay in the place
no hotel you'll you'll pay for it i
think that would be fun that would be
fun
yeah sometimes i do like kind of lay in
bed thinking about like the people like
that in my life
uh that like either didn't believe or
like were negative in some kind of way
and thinking about like you know talking
to them now and kind of checking in you
know checking in yeah yeah like you know
worked hard made it work you know you
didn't believe in me you know how did
you make twenty thousand dollars in a
month with ten thousand subscribers
we had a couple videos that hit big and
they they didn't grow your sub count a
ton with the video no i mean we were
growing fast and so
i'm not you know i'm this has got off a
memory you know this is like
late 2016 early 2017
so you know three years ago and so i'm
trying to remember it specifically what
it is
but it was something like that like we
were probably like under 50k for sure
uh and made like three grand and then
like the 10 grand
i think what it was actually this is a
milestone that i remember very
specifically is if we could hit a
hundred thousand subscribers i'll quit
my job
so we were at 100k
and that was also the same time i
remember showing my boss to like prove i
was so excited like yeah like i made 20
grand like that's awesome
that might have been like the month
before but before
i talked to him and before i could move
out we were already at 200k oh my gosh
we like doubled that fast and then like
before you knew it i think like a month
and a half later we had a million
so we had like tremendous exponential
growth because we were riding trends and
the algorithm was simpler back then
uh i mean i wouldn't say it's any more
complicated it's just different and i
just like figured it out and so i knew
how to make content win and how to
combine trends and how to merge
audiences to just
to just one like if you typed in fidget
spinner i would come up first
back when like fidget spinners were like
a big trend like if you type in nerf i'm
probably ranked like third like if you
just go on google nerf like i would be
there like i was like maxing out all the
seo on all the topics like nerf slime
prank fidget spinners hoverboard
backflip
that stuff and just
maxed out on it all were you doing a lot
of networking at the time no zero no
collabs nothing that's incredible did it
all without ever meeting a youtuber
until we were
like i don't know one and a half million
or more mm-hmm and he was a car channel
and had 500k
but like not like a big channel what's
the car channel uh jr garage oh yeah
those guys jeff yeah don't they comment
on yeah shout out to jl garage you guys
are watching i haven't seen those guys
in a long time but yeah we filmed a few
really cool videos actually
so what we wanted to do with um and my
brother stephen was friends with those
guys that's how i met them
so they had they were like in high
school it's a craziest thing so they
were high schoolers i think he was 17.
uh j.r was 17 and had a lamborghini
living in yeah i thought it was a viper
well he had a viper you did viper first
and yeah we had a viper at all this in
time what was the car he drove
he's i'm telling you he has so many cars
it's crazy and this is back in
2017. no this is it this is it driving
this is his initial video was driving my
dodge viper to high school at 17
and then he had this one posted later
driving my lamborghini to high school at
17. funny supercar reaction three years
ago that's around the time that we met
him and his brother and they roll up to
my house with a tesla model x p90d or
whatever the maxed one is you know and
then a guyardo and a viper they rolled
up like that is so cool so and we had
content planned so again this is back
when i was like topping my analytics
strategy game
and we wanted to combine fidget spinners
which were like mega hot with
lamborghini which is
according to my research super hot so we
were going to do like a lamborghini
fidget spinner by making a giant
lamborghini and putting it like on the
wheels as like a spinners you know oh
wow so we just like he just let us hot
glue it to the rim we like made this
spray paint it was super cool it looked
like a giant fidget spinner out of
cardboard and then we put like a bearing
in the middle from a fidget spinner and
then just like literally just glued it
with hot glue to the lamborghini room so
you drive around you have these like
you know like spinners but they were
like
it was a cool thing it went viral you
know multi-million views
um
so it was just crazy yeah that's
incredible i feel like the algorithm
used to be so much more simple back then
like three years ago it was honestly you
put like for us you put passive income
in the title 100k views easy which back
then for a finance channel that's like
that's the equivalent of a million views
now so i'll just do views now
passive income million views uh talk
about a lamborghini lamborghini in the
background 500 000 views i bought a
lamborghini a million views now that
doesn't work anymore now you can't do
that that's boring that's actually
literally what we did lemonade was so
hot that we went out and we bought a
lamborghini and we made more money
because we bought that lamborghini than
if we didn't buy the lamborghini
that doesn't work so well today although
no it does not but because everyone has
lambos now because everyone that's like
the new baseline you know you gotta get
a private jet next okay that's the next
step but no but see you have to appeal
to like 25 and under 2 500 they don't
care about private jets
they don't have it like posters of it on
their walls outside of music videos as
much as like lambo is just such a brand
what do kids like now because i feel
like even just a few years ago it was
lamborghini
what is it still a lambo in a lot of
senses there's more everyone has a lambo
so there's more competition for content
i thought it was tesla
worked for me
tesla worked for me
78 tesla model 3. i don't know if it's
kids i think it's a little bit older
people that are very into like i'm into
tesla's a lot of my friends my age you
know as opposed to like you know you ask
a six-year-old what's the coolest car
they're probably not saying tesla
i mean they're very cool cars but
they're probably saying some kind of
fancy sports car
you know more colors and stuff like that
let's talk about that lambo that you
bought because in that video that i
watched of yours you said that you spent
everything to get this lambo like you
literally had like zero dollars after
this transaction what was that like
and uh how long did it take for you to
like save up for the lambo and did you
go into it with 100 confidence that it
would pay for itself
no we didn't go 100 confidence so
we had so we were shopping for a lambo
and i think we paid like for this one uh
like a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars it was uh
right right lamborghini got in 2012. so
it's only a few years old very low miles
we got like the green like it's like
this color green fruit ithaca verde
ithaca and so we found uh we went all
over we did find one
and so we like flew up or drove up to
like ohio or something like that and we
like saw it we told the guy like this is
it don't we negotiate we bought the car
handshake
and then you know like before we're like
officially signing papers and
transferring money we had to like wait
for our next adsense to come in just so
we could pay it we didn't even have the
money wow we knew what we were going to
get paid because they tell you estimated
yeah but you have to wait a month for it
to come
so we had to like wait for a disa we're
like making up excuses of like what's
happening because he's like where's my
money like i thought i was gonna get
paid monday we didn't get paid until
like thursday that week so we had to
like wait so it finally hit the bank and
then we turned around and shot it and he
was like zeroed out we had like a couple
of thousand bucks left you didn't want
to get a loan or anything we never even
thought about it we didn't even know
that no clue what a loan was i mean i
did but like we didn't like consider
those things no we just paid cash
and we paid all the cash we had and you
know we're only like a few months into
youtube so we made that money
months into youtube yeah buying a
lamborghini yeah wow yeah still living
in my parents house we bought a buy a
lamborghini before we decided to move
out how much of that was like you liking
the lambo versus how much of that was
like a calculated risk to yeah i mean
i'd be lying if i said that we weren't
like super hyped naturally right yeah
you know being the only like kids in
virginia
uh just graduated college so it was 20
yeah
2016.
um
so yeah that was cool but you know in
hindsight it was such an incredible
investment we made a lot of videos with
it it's more than paid itself off
multiple times over
we used it for branding for a music
video show the love
which was the first uh piece of music
i've ever written i've never played any
instrument or anything we write this
song and it's over 120 million views now
really mm-hmm
it's like
how much did how much does that make 120
million can you can you tell us i don't
have uh access to that anymore but
it's definitely over a hundred thousand
dollars so even just that single video
alone is probably closer to 200k wow uh
revenue it's very low cpm because it's
just short you only get one ad you're
not gonna put an ad like in the middle
of a music video people are listening to
it that would be funny that's something
i would do yeah
my music video guys would have an ad
that every other minute you should do
that that would be fun it's like right
as the chorus is coming
right the clown ty lopez
yeah but it's crazy you know because
like that video
a platinum record is 150 million like
plays or whatever there's different
metrics that equate to different things
so if that video hits 150 million which
it's on track to it gets like a million
or two a month every month for since we
made it wow uh it's gonna go platinum
and so i'll be like a platinum record
artist which is like a weird concept to
me because it's you know it's like a
song for a young audience
um and it did like beyond well but again
we had like seo behind it and
branding behind it the lambo behind it
back when lambo is big and it's just
solidified itself wow youtube that just
keeps on chugging
so you've then transformed that gallardo
into now you have an aventador s
and you've got a countach
when did you get the countach
i got that one
um i don't know almost a year ago
how much was that that's gonna be like
300 250. it would be but i got it for
under a hundred thousand
wait how it's because it's a replica is
it really yeah can we say that is that
or do you know i mean i don't really
like say that okay
we can mute it yeah you want us to mute
it we can mute it it's up to you man i
don't i don't want to put you on the
spot for anything you don't want out
there no i mean i'm open with my stuff
okay i mean i don't advertise certain
things but it's not that i'm not open
about it okay
but yeah i mean that was uh i had no
idea yeah so it's a really really good
one so it's actually the second one that
i've bought wow and the first one i
think the countachess are amazing and
knowing my use case for a countach
uh
i couldn't do it with the real one
yeah i'd want to drive it the way i just
you know like i use my stuff yeah i use
my cars and i'm not going to use like a
that much money on a [ __ ] top wow it
looked great
jack you should put some b-roll off of
this car here
it looks so good now i couldn't tell on
the interior it looked like a pontiac
fiero in the interior i'm not sure if
that's just no it's not that's just how
they are that's how they are
just the engine it's got more
real countach parts in it than not
wow it's a very high like yeah that's
crazy and that's got to stand for 100
that's going to be the real dimensions
of the car it's the perfect dimension
same horsepower same it's got countach
wheels countach emblems and interior and
seat belts and radio steering wheel
it's crazy i don't know who built this
thing but it's got like more countach on
it than probably some countaches is it
still very quick like it's it's fast
yeah do you know what kind of engine it
has it's got like a
like a chevy something in there like a
v8 it's not like a v12 i think they
usually have 350 engines
yeah
i know a lot about this because i kid
you not i was like 18 years old i wanted
a countach replica
really badly because think of it like i
i had just gotten out of high school and
i wanted a lamborghini but obviously i
don't have the money for a lamborghini
so i felt like well for 40 grand if i
could see him 40 grand i could get a
countach like this or they had diablo
replicas
i knew someone who had a diablo yeah
really replica it looks awesome yeah
yeah you couldn't even tell yeah
um but now for something like a countach
i love those cars but they're like 250
to like 400 grand and you never want to
drive it because of how rare it is uh
every mile that you put on that car i
don't know how much value you lose on
that risk
yeah so to get a replica like that for
100 and just drive the snot out of it
that would be kind of cool
makes me almost want want one now well i
might be selling mine if you want it
really
because it's not very drivable why
because you can't see out of it which is
the same for
again it's the same dimensions and seats
and everything you just can't see the
shape and how low you saw how low it is
yeah um it's so low the windows are on
an angle like this like all windows
well you can but it takes three two by
fours to get it in and out of the
driveway okay because it's you know kind
of steep it doesn't have a front lift so
like as you pull down you come at an
angle and i'll shove one two by four
i'll tell you to pull up i put another
one no joke yeah like literally it takes
three pieces of wood to get it in and
out of the driveway and you've had a
positive roi in the car
well so this is the second one that i've
owned the first one i owned i got like a
real junker but it looked clean which is
all i really wanted for you know content
so i got that one and i paid 30 for it
had it for like a few months and then
sold it for 47. so i made 17 on it and
made content on it and drove it around
have fun with it
which was awesome uh and then i turned
around and buy this one for like some uh
like 80 something i paid i think
um and then again i made content on it
but it's just
not they're just so hard to drive like
even like the aventador like awesome car
that does have a front lift so some more
modern features isn't it like it's like
riding a roller coaster would you ride a
roller coaster every day
no no but you'll ride it like you know a
couple times this weekend and then not
for two months and they'll be excited to
go back to the theme park right it's
like that but the countach is like the
scariest one
and it's so like it's just so hard to
see it's just so inconvenient in every
way it's actually a good like tester to
see if you'd actually appreciate and
drive a real one
that's true which is higher risk but the
same shape same horsepower same
you know no power steering in the front
all that kind of stuff it drives very
sometimes that could be good to do that
to get out of your system like i really
wanted this rolex it was a rose gold
uh rolex with a uh olive dial
and it was beautiful and i really wanted
this watch bad it's like 40 grand oh my
god so i got a replica version of the
same watch for like 350 bucks yeah and
got it out of my system within a weekend
yeah see that's what i mean like perfect
yeah now i'm good now now i know what
it's like i don't need that i saved a
lot of money yeah why are you laughing
no it's smart that's very smart i think
it's cool
yes it's good money i think it's really
exciting yeah that's good
i should wear it on the podcast at some
point why don't you it's right over
there all right let's also grab it i'll
watch it i'll show you the watch whoops
oh thank you yeah this is the uh this is
a rolex
so obviously the weight is is really off
the weight is off the weight is really
it's really light for what it is if that
were real gold it would be a very heavy
watch okay but that's it like visually
you wouldn't you wouldn't see any
difference just until you feel it you're
like wow this this is obviously not gold
yeah i would never probably spend money
on a watch really yeah i see i love them
see something like this i feel like is a
work of art at least i'm not into it
like
i mean your audience probably based on
things i'm saying things probably i
spent like crazy money and i'm like
crazy with my money and stuff
i think about it
and like even for the aventador s which
is outrageous it's a 495 000 sticker
price
but i didn't buy it brand new
do you buy it or you leased it no i
bought it you bought it yeah why why not
lease that car that's it that's an easy
write-off to lease okay it's an easy
right off to lease but here
here's my justification actually was
gonna make like a whole video kind of
like your tesla video on it
so i it's a 500 000 car i got it on the
second owner so it's slightly used and i
spent uh
350 or something on it
or 340 or whatever something like that
so
because it's
three years old um two to three years
old
it's already lower on its depreciation
curve and that curve is flattening out
and depending on how things go i could
own this car for three years and only
like i'm only really paying the the
delta the difference between when i buy
it into when i sell it that's really the
number that matters obviously there's
more risk sales tax
there's sales tax and stuff too which i
didn't really kind of
consider but anyways there's lots of
examples just like that other
the the first kentuc i bought i bought
it and sold it for 17 grand more like
four months later
you know what i mean so like there's
possibilities for this s
uh either increasing in value holding
its value or decreasing in value but
even if it decreases it's not going to
be by much
i could probably own this lambo for just
a few thousand dollars maybe 20 grand 30
grand over the course of six months to a
year to like a year and a half depending
on what i do with it
all the while generate revenue with it
by making videos content
uh have it elevate the brand and photos
and you know being an owner of a
crazy event or s also personal enjoyment
all these things factor in and then when
i go to sell it even if i like smashed
it it would still be worth like a
hundred and fifty
like literally just completely wrecked
the front of the car it'd probably be
worth almost two hundred thousand
dollars i think that's yeah i respect
that because if you lease it you know
how much you're paying in a monthly
lease like oh probably 50 yeah six grand
a month and you're and you have to put
like 30 grand down
that's probably true yeah and they limit
your miles to 2 500 miles a year
and it's like four dollars a mile if you
go above per mile or something crazy
i've already put
a few thousand miles on my car and i've
only had it for a few months because i
use it you know for content enjoyment
and don't have to pay a dollar per mile
yeah
i paid i got myself in a corner on this
one i can't spend any amount of money
without people getting very upset at me
i can't do that if i got a lamborghini
like that people immediately turn their
back like graham you've taught us save
our money and now you go and buy a
lamborghini i can't do that
yeah
i don't think it would be too bad
anymore i think it would be i mean yeah
so it would last a long amount of time i
don't know graham has this like argument
in his head all the time and he thinks
that like people would really be
affected if he were to go and do
something like that i think on the other
hand as long as you could justify it the
way that you did whereas like i mean to
be completely honest you would get
personal enjoyment out of it you know
and there is a dollar amount that you
could put on that i don't see you
enjoying a lambo very much though why
i feel like for you i mean it's a it's a
lot it's like even for me like i kind of
question like should i is it time to get
rid of this thing you know should i like
get my money back on it or should i keep
it i kind of go back and forth because
it's a ton of money to be locked up in a
car yeah oh also the decision between
financing
um and just paying cash for it was also
something that i thought of too
for it too and because like taxes were
the same fine if i finance it i'll just
be paying more interest
but because of the different cash flow
circumstances i was in it was just
better just to pay it off since i don't
have use for that money currently at the
moment so it would be cheaper to avoid
interest and just pay it off okay the
interest is a write-off though i view it
as the interest of write-off and you
just invest the difference
okay well i'm learning more about okay
but you know i put some thought as
opposed to going and buying you know
just random stuff um
and i always try to have whatever i do
invest my money and be a positive return
i think for the most part i i do pretty
well what about the hummer
the hummer okay
yeah same kind of idea that was like a
hundred thousand dollars
um
i don't plan on ever selling that car i
love that thing and so i just use it for
personal enjoyment and for content and
it's
i wouldn't necessarily say it's paid
itself off it's hard to track that kind
of thing but we've done videos that have
done 10 million plus and actually it's
100 paid itself off probably four times
over now i'm starting to think of the
content we've done we've done videos
that have 22 million views on it and it
was last to leave the hummer and we just
put my friends in the hummer and lastly
it's got 22 million views
and that's more what do they win
uh
like 10
it's pretty good good deal not bad yeah
could you go over each car that you have
right now currently yeah what do you
have uh okay so it's a 2004 hummer h1
i got the
lamborghini eventer s the countach
i just bought a limo
kind of crazy yeah that's super cool i'm
gonna pick my friend up tonight at this
point
right 22 grand 22 grand for a limousine
man we did a lot of research i actually
have a video that kind of shows a little
bit of that we drove all over like we
were in palm palm desert you know
looking for one we were somewhere around
here then we drove all the way to fresno
for this we found such a great example
it's a really great vehicle very well
taken care of so very happy about that
one we're going to get some fun use out
of that and we're going to last leave
limo it's probably going to hopefully
we'll do well um
okay so i have a smart car
which is awesome i really like that one
too i actually drive that one probably
the most
little tiny two-door smart car that's
fun it's like a little go-kart it's just
fun like it's just feels like you're
driving a go-kart on the road
uh another one of my favorites is the
1964 volkswagen dune buggy
uh that one is again like i don't plan
on ever selling it love that car it's so
fun um it's basically an old volkswagen
beetle that's been converted
uh i have a lincoln navigator that one's
elise that's kind of more like a work
truck you know we use it to haul people
and uh super fancy super
nice um
i have a porsche macan s
we just wrapped pink hmm super cool it's
outside right now that's what you drove
okay we'll check it out it's like bubble
gum pink and diamond white and we
painted the rims powder coated black and
it looks really fresh just got it back
today
so that was a surprise for liz that's
her car oh cool
um i wonder if i'm forgetting anything
that's gonna be a nice problem to have
like i don't know if i'm forgetting
anything how old are you
i just turned 27. okay yeah
that's awesome what's your net worth
i don't know i'm not even sure
so all right like what's in my bank
account networks i think it's more than
that no it would be it would be so yeah
so i say that kind of like jokingly to
everybody in the podcast yeah because
it's like my thing is what's your credit
score how many credits
i'll tell you what happens if you google
it oh google said what actually looks
like
let's see let's see how accurate this is
and we'll go because they'll probably be
other answers so scroll through like the
top few results and
we'll kind of average it maybe do you
think people are people are out there
like trying to calculate what your net
worth is i bet it's gonna be lower than
what it is it's gonna be lower
i don't know actually pretty good three
three and a half million is what google
says google says millions
three and a half
i don't know man because i don't know
about your investments
i don't know about you i'm going to say
i don't want to i don't want to
i'm going to go and say
google says you're not worth a six and a
half what is okay can we just define the
definition so okay so net worth would be
all of your assets minus whatever
liabilities you have but it's an asset
count is like my youtube channel which
no no currently no no we're not going to
count that would be like your cars minus
any debt like if i died today in my
channel liberty like everything dies
we're not counting your channel yeah
okay no channel so it would be whatever
cash you have in the bank whatever
investments you have whatever the values
of your cars are do you have any loans
or anything
no so it would be the value of uh the
cash in the bank the cars
investments and then anything else that
you may have that has value aside from
like a youtube channel it could be like
social media because i i don't think
it's so fair to not count the youtube
channel because like that's what i could
sell it tomorrow for
and then we'll include it at the end
okay
and so wait is so you're asking me what
yeah
i don't know i'd have to add it all up
but
i'm sure yeah
position or something
no but i'm up so i started investing
yeah and i'm up okay
just in the past few months i'm up like
40 on my e-trade nice crazy killing it
right what investment well tesla is
going crazy yep nice i think i made uh
10 grand today on tesla good
crazy yes you you two hundred and
something thousand dollars and how many
shares of tesla yeah i don't think they
have a hundred thousand
to make ten thousand because it was a
ten big ten percent today
i'd have to see how much i can i don't
know if it's a hundred though do you
have like what like 40 grand in tesla i
would say closer to like yet between
yeah like 40 30 100 shares you could
sell covered calls on tesla i think i
put 10 grand in tesla last night before
bed and then today it went up big so i
threw a little bit in it bumped yeah i
think today it's up ten percent yeah
pretty sure i watched
what i do all day i can see i can check
i'll see i'm curious all day you have 10
10.2 i was point two percent off today
wow graham but look at this
gosh you know what's crazy i bought in
right after the announcement too of it
uh hitting s p 500 and even then i'm
like oh i'm buying high but i'm just
gonna hold it and it went up again and
i'm i'm up
uh
like 30 something 35 a share
on that
tesla's remarkable
name one person that you know is
actually down on tesla okay from holding
tesla
yeah i know someone or no me
i'm down on tesla okay so even after it
went up today uh yeah
and i'm not like a short term holder
like i've had it for months right i
bought it because so it was going up a
lot right after the split and i bought
right at the peak my average cost per
share is like it's like 500 bucks
post split which is like i did not tell
you to do that by the way i said no you
didn't i needed to absolve myself from
you i went against everything that i've
i've learned in investing you know it
just kept going up and i figured well
it's gonna keep going up right no it
doesn't okay you bought at the peak like
as soon as you bought it yes the whole
stock market was like yeah
yeah you're right all the way down yeah
so i i only put in two grand but somehow
like two days later i was down four
hundred dollars i literally at one point
was down like seven hundred dollars on a
two thousand dollar investment and that
was like a couple weeks later on tesla
and so i've i've you know rode tesla for
a long time now and now i'm only down 50
bucks so that feels road tesla i've rode
tesla everyone go get rodenty ones these
are great mics
so i do have a decent chunk in tesla all
right yeah it's over i figured i figured
see yep over a hundred grand or a
hundred yeah yeah like 100 yeah yeah
that's awesome you're stoked so it's
doing well yeah i made like a i said 11
6 today
that's pretty well that's like the first
like i'm just barely getting into stock
market yeah so where else are you
investing because we had a brief talk
about this before
and you were saying that your biggest
investment has been back in the channel
yeah trying to make more money
are you starting to diversify away from
that
i mean a little bit in a sense like i
want to get into real estate i want to
buy another property but it's kind of
like a
uh
content location property
uh it's like a lake house right so
i mean personal use would love to have
it also
uh but amazing content could film there
so that's sort of an investment that's
diversified a little bit but it's still
very content focused yeah but that's the
thing that you like the more i spend on
the videos
you know the more that they make you
know it's some kind of correlation
at the same time though as you're making
so much money i think i'm sure i'm sure
you know this storing away a lot you
know would be really good
yeah i'm so i'm so paranoid it's like
the algorithm just has a little switch
and it's like switches off for a little
bit and it's like oh
there it goes there it goes how long is
that going to take to switch
though it seems like you definitely know
exactly what you're doing i mean you've
been doing this for years now you know i
think it's definitely calculated
you know my approach to things
definitely
uh but i agree like if it goes weird
tomorrow like
you know it's
things change fast
uh and so that's why i mean i've always
been doing like sep ira stuff from day
one
always trying to do the best i can for
like setting up my retirement and you
know i've had some good people that you
know on my team along the way and i
just slowly try to learn and absorb as
much as i can about like taxes and
investing and
uh you know now i'm looking into like
real estate so i'm learning about like
loans
um
and you know there's all so many
different kinds of everything and so you
know really working on being better
financially to set me up for long term
especially through like road bumps and
you know stuff like that yeah i mean i
would even take for you like 20 of your
income and just pretend it doesn't exist
that'll set your you'll be set for life
yeah
because i'm just like i said i'm just
paranoid about the algorithm so far the
algorithm's good
all hail the algorithm but uh man it
sometimes just takes one or two bad
videos in a row i would say 20 depending
on your spending and depending on your
income so if you like if all of your
spending is really crucial to the
business by all means i think obviously
you're going to get way better roi and
right now is the time to keep going on
that
but
did you see would you say you have any
like unnecessary spending in any area
um
let's talk a little bit about frugality
and spending i'm pretty frugal i don't
buy a lot of stuff i mean i buy cars i
love my cars um
but you know apart from like the lambo
and stuff they're they're pretty you
know they're not the most expensive cars
in the world um
but yeah i don't really buy a lot of
stuff for myself like you know like the
shoes and stuff that i wear are
generally like
the ones i got for my birthday like last
year and they're all like dirty and
stuff like that like i don't
i never go shopping for myself i never
like get clothes and stuff like that
like this was again this is i got a
fancy shirt you know it's like the one
off-white shirt that i own and it was a
christmas present last year i wear it
all the time you know so i'm pretty
frugal when it comes to that stuff i
spend most of my
money like i just love projects and each
video is like a project i love to build
stuff like growing up you know like i
taught myself to weld at 12.
you know my parents got me a water for
my 12th birthday
and just did that every day just would
cut metal build things it would build
go-karts and mini bikes we built i built
a uh restored a jeep before i had my
driver's license um before i was 16. we
still have it um
you know stuff like that like i just
that's what i love to do like i'm kind
of like a didn't really grow up on a
farm but i'm kind of like kind of like a
farm boy like that do you watch michael
reeves yeah okay so reminds me of his
robotics building videos yeah i think i
can see there's a lot in common between
us he's definitely taking the robotic
stuff that that's a lot that i learned
like throughout school
to that very high level he's very
talented so i have a huge appreciation
for the stuff that he does because i
understand all the disciplines that he
gets into yeah and it's very impressive
to do all those different languages and
combine all those different systems
together to you know make youtube video
also his directing and editing skills
are outstanding yeah his videos his his
videos are just put together so well
starting to finish start to finish yeah
awesome you know huge respect yeah yeah
you guys are very opposite to in the
swearing
you don't swear i don't swear every
other word out of his mouth is is is it
bad it's a naughty word a video that
graham and him did together it was a man
gnarly i had to like
cut
some of these things mid-sentence and
try to like mesh them together so it
didn't sound like i was bleeping
anything like in his natural language
like sitting here talking so much so
much really every other word was like
the f word yeah
it was fun yeah like it was interesting
to see because i even on a personal
level i had i know nobody that's like
that but that's interesting it's funny
though it's really funny and i asked
it's like why don't you just not swear
in your videos and your videos would do
like so much better and it's just like
no it's just him that's it so
does he have low cpm yes
yeah all of his income is pretty much
sponsorships yeah
that's a that's a bummer
but that's what i mean it's a sacrifice
that you make right but but my thing was
a little bit like yeah
that turned off it ran out of battery
space or not battery space storage but i
got to delete some other stuff on there
i mean it's up to you do you want to
roll with it or what i think you say we
just roll with it okay yeah
but uh yeah but i asked him but just
don't swear
no but it makes sense part of part of
his appeal i think is just in his
vocabulary and it makes it really it's
just it's fun it's funny it is
definitely part of his like uh his humor
and his brand um which i think helps him
set apart you know but at the loss of
like low cpm or not monetized yeah
that's a that's a it's a big trade-off
right so he's gotta have great
relationships with sponsorships like i
couldn't i couldn't function only on
sponsors i really don't do a lot of
brand deals i'm getting more into it now
and
the last couple months have been awesome
um liz on the other hand crushes brand
deals um but like i couldn't function my
primary income definitely comes from
adsense for sure yeah yeah a huge part
so you do you go out of your way then to
make sure you don't swear is it pretty
natural that you just
don't know it's pretty natural i mean i
don't i haven't sweared once being here
and i'm not like oh catching myself
right like i just uh i don't i mean a
little bit here and there yeah um just
like in my normal life
so on videos like if i stub my toe like
i might kind of have a little bit more
of a tendency to want to
but you know i just have made so many
videos that uh it you know it's easy
yeah like i don't think it's necessary
at all i don't think it enhances the
viewing experience but it certainly can
decrease it for some audience members
cut it out if you do end up swinging
we'll just do another take or uh stub
your toe again
go fall again yeah oh yeah we'll work
around it i mean it's so infrequent and
it's so minor when it does happen or if
a guest does that maybe is a less where
like we you know we like to keep it
clean and
that's our brand and people really
appreciate that especially parents of
younger audience members they love to
know like hey you know your content is
uh super clean i don't worry about you
guys like cursing and stuff yeah jack
has to constantly hold back all the time
that's not true do i have a potty mouth
gram no no not at all i'm very clean
believe it or not my early videos had a
lot of swearing in them yeah like a lot
of swearing oh jeez
um i just thought it was fun and it got
people's attention it does and it was so
different from everything else on
youtube because you'd have these very
serious finance people that were so
uptight and then i'd come on like what's
up you guys you know this this f this is
made all these jokes and people loved it
in the beginning but you cut it out the
video you filmed with him you cut it all
out and made it clean or no so i i
privated some of the earlier videos that
had an obscene amount of swearing in
them and then i turned things around
about six months in
and uh it was because the youtube
channel started getting more views and i
was still making my primary income as a
real estate agent and i didn't want that
to impact my business as a real estate
agent if people saw me on youtube just
going like swearing and making kind of
like potty jokes
i didn't want that to impact me on that
side so i just stomped it all together
and then it's i've gotten such a habit
now of that where i just naturally just
don't swear anymore
it's good though like i saw a comment
because we used to have like a placard
like a name plate on graham's desk that
said do epic s word okay and we ended up
removing that and then i saw a comment
on the video that we changed the placard
out and it said it was like thank you so
much you don't know how like important
this is to me because now i can put on
these videos when my kid is in the room
and i'm just like wow like yes they've
seen yeah and it doesn't taste like they
can now watch it with their kids that's
huge that was my original complaint uh
when i first started making videos a lot
of people were telling me like i can't
play or like my 12 year old was watching
your thing and then i heard the f word
and i had to have him take it off which
is a shame because i like the
information but please stop swearing or
give us a heads up that like there's
going to be bad languages i had the
video playing in front of like my my
family and i could imagine that the
reaction hey let's see how this guy
makes passive income and then it's yeah
just like a whole bunch of streams right
but yeah
it didn't really change the videos much
people enjoyed it same with the
nameplate the nameplate i kept for years
um and it was changed because the
algorithm decided to demonetize the
video because of that little word on the
screen
and i figured well it's not worth it
let's go and change it to something else
and the new sign is just as good
no difference
that's interesting so it actually
registered like that did i never
expected i never had that before and
i was so upset because i had a 100
uh rating accuracy for my uh for
monetization
and i said this video was suitable for
all advertisers and then a manual review
found it not to be and they docked me on
that and so i don't have a 100 accuracy
rating anymore i was really upset about
that
so well that's why you know don't curse
it's a good lesson you know for you guys
i didn't think on a little nameplate
because i didn't curse it's just a word
on the screen in a nameplate right
yeah
no it's interesting well youtube's
getting smarter yeah
you know it's uh youtube is successful
as a platform because they have
great relationships with uh brands so
when brands get upset then
youtube has less like you know adsense
and money to pay and so and then
creators will make less content and so
they need to be very tight with all the
brands
and so they need to be very strict on
like cursing and things that the brands
don't want their uh ads to play over
yeah i think one of the big things that
happened for the ad pocalypse early on
was like people were making like videos
or something and then there would be
like a honey nut cheerio commercial that
would come up right whatever so i know
like walmart pulled out coca-cola pulled
out
and uh i don't know how much of that
though was to save face for those
companies versus their actual concern
over those matters
i have a feeling a lot of it people were
looking at the companies like hey do you
endorse this and obviously they go well
no we don't endorse this so we got to
pull out what's the brand association in
a way is that what you're saying yeah
how much is um
it what how did i word this i just i
blanked on this
are you listening jack oh yeah jack was
tuning in
no it's the brand so it's like
uh you know it's subliminal i guess but
like if you see like a crazy video
um
and then like an ad comes up it seems
like they're kind of related or being
sponsored by that but i'm weird like
that but like i never put the two and
two together i like if i watch nelk for
instance whatever ads i see on nelk's
channel if we see any anymore i never
think that like oh they're they're
endorsing milk i just i see that it's
just like same exact thing
as like an ad read or like an actual
sponsorship because in certain sponsors
like they want to make sure that in the
video it doesn't contain some sort of
like illicit material but i just
wouldn't see that as an endorsement
but it's the same thing it's the exact
same thing think about the opposite way
where they pay an actor to say a certain
thing in their commercial
you know you get like a football you
know nfl player or something to like
push the cheerios or whatever you see
that that obviously is a brand
association okay so what if it appears
on his video and it's just the ad but
it's on his video then it's it's
connected i think it's essentially this
exactly yeah they're worried about it
maybe maybe not for you as an individual
but maybe as a population or
demographics are more like prone to like
oh i don't know why
this is supporting or vice versa why
honey nut cheerios is supporting that's
weird
maybe cut out the eye okay so this might
be a little uh abstract but one thing
that really fascinates me is
the character of different content
creators and how like what character
traits they have used to help them get
to where they are today because like
every time that i meet someone that's
like successful on youtube they always
their personal character is so different
than anyone i know in my own life like
say i know like 30 people i have 30
friends they're all of their characters
are like somewhat similar but like every
time i meet someone who has like a
successful youtube channel it's so
different like graham was not i'm not
saying you're different than what i
thought of you but just you're like i
haven't met many people at all later
just like like you you know and same
goes for a lot of these wait so you're
saying i was different from no no no no
from what i expected just like in person
like you you just your character is just
different from what okay a lot of people
i've met and same goes for you like like
it seems like i'm just i'm just
fascinated what like your character how
that has allowed for you you think to to
get to where you are today like my
personal character
your traits personalities like as as me
or as like on camera because i feel like
there's also you know some people are
like i'm not not as what's on camera
okay
i think it's huge i think it's really
big i've always felt unique
just i always just felt like different
um
than all my friends and stuff like i
always just kind of felt that i don't
know
um and that's so like i've always been
very largely creative
and um
and then in college i was diagnosed with
like learning disabilities which is uh
something that
i never really knew about so i'm like
dyslexic add and like uh you know some
decoding things so i'm like really bad
at reading
and i never like i always just struggled
through it and it wasn't so bad that yo
this kid can't read so i was just like
struggled in school
um but i always found that
i think it's because of those things i'm
very creative because it my brain just
works differently and i've always
noticed that from a very young age
i've been very
like add for example is i feel like it's
very misunderstood but i'm like i can
get super obsessive and hyper focused so
if i'm like filming a video or just get
into youtube i'll just like obsess over
it and nothing else in my life exists
except for youtube and i'll just get
like 100 miles an hour on it so i think
i'm very good at like getting stuff done
that way when i'm focused
and then being like dyslexic and like
seeing things backwards and stuff i
am very creative and i think i get that
from my mom and she's an artist
and so i can come up with like really
interesting ideas that people like
wouldn't come up with i feel like a lot
of like as like a like a population and
lots of people are very similar i'm like
one more kind of like on the outlier
just being a unique different kind of
like cognitive
process i guess the way like i think
through stuff so i think that's made me
a unique person and had interesting
perspectives to things and i think
that's absolutely helped me take a
unique approach
uh to content and stuff like that and so
you saying that like i am different
like i believe that you know yeah i
appreciate that i like to be different i
strive to be different
um i think like being normal and fitting
in is like i don't like that you know
yeah to some extent you know for some
things but
so
i think it's huge definitely
yeah it's just it was fascinating
because the way that you think and from
the video that i watched of you it's
like
like you come off as like as having such
like a laser focus on certain things and
like even like talking to you right now
it seems like you know you could have
some sort of laser focus at the same
time the type of content you create like
i feel like that requires a little bit
of a like sporadic mindset oh definitely
very sporadic yeah which i think is also
a little bit
very descriptive like my mindset like
i'll bounce and i'll be obsessed with
this car for like three weeks i won't
sleep because i'm so obsessed with like
researching
like for the countach i probably lost
like three weeks of sleep couldn't think
i couldn't barely even film videos i was
just so obsessed with it was like
financially worth it no it's not it's
it's it's dangerous so i'm working on
like you know taming that but i just get
so crazy obsessed i'll stay up till 4am
just doing stuff you know um
and so part of my decision was yo just
buy this car so you can stop thinking
about it and move it get back to me
like at least yeah well i made money on
the first one i sold it so like it
wasn't that good this one's more
expensive
but like part of it was like yo i don't
think it's a great idea but then the
other part and talk to my friends like
dude just go buy that card just buy it
today i think liz was like just buy the
car like you can afford it you will make
videos worst case you'll sell it for
something lesser than you bought it for
but we'll make as much content to try to
fix it but at least you get back into
the office and we can make content you
know so stuff like that
but also even within content i'll have
like you know building the lego yacht
and then i'll do some like something
completely like a prank thing like just
bouncing around like this you know
um did i just turn off yeah that's
fascinating well i guess another here's
another thought i just had is like
i can't focus on anything unless i
obsess on it
that's an 80d thing that's an 80d thing
i think right like you can't just like
give me like something normal and just
give me 10 no i need to like
really obsess on it so one thing i'm
actually excited about is
i'm starting to get like obsessive with
like investing in stock markets which is
something i've been putting off since
the start of my career i've just been
like sitting money in the bank losing
the depreciation not working for me
which i know is bad but i'm like okay i
don't have time to think about it i
don't time to think about but now i'm
like getting into it and i'm hoping that
continues so i can really like set
myself up you know like there's
definitely a balance i'm sure for you
your time is probably best spent just
creating content just being
like the career share but i can't just
have like you know the money that i may
just sit there exactly like i had it i
had to like at least put in a money
market which i haven't even done you
have a financial advisor and stuff no
not yet oh
i got a good man i mean honestly you
don't have to pay like once you're down
for that oh
no you don't even need that
i mean yeah realistically you don't need
it just put like 80 index fund yep and
then like 20 percent you can play around
with on robin hood or something maybe
like a few percent like bond it's easy
it's easy to make a fidelity account and
just do one of their fidelity free index
funds you have any questions we can
answer them right here we can answer
them after the podcast whenever you want
yeah you wanted to set up my full
portfolio and just get me set for life
we literally don't yeah we literally
will alright great i brought all my how
much work how much you want to invest
it should be a set percentage out of
your income that you like i have a lot
of like money in the bank that i just
don't need
yeah how much
a lot
seven figures are six
seven
oh
jeez man yeah
uh why why did you invest this sooner
well because i had well i guess you
missed that okay like i just haven't
gotten too okay so i would say of this
did you already pay your taxes for this
year you do okay so uh for this year and
i don't know you pay quarterly yeah okay
okay so what i would say is
i mean i have a lot to play invest half
of it
i think your other half
keep it cash dollar cost average it for
you
that's kind of what i'm doing i'm also
doing it just to kind of like ease
myself into trusting putting it
somewhere versus somewhere where i know
it'll sit yeah so what i would do is
take 50 000 a month or 100 000 a month
of that
and just index fund it a total stock
market index fund which is what fatality
500 or something it's going to be
everything so yeah multiple qqq is that
one qqq is a little bit more targeted
towards towards check
but fidelity has one it's just a total
stock market index fund it covers
everything in the stock market and just
throw 50 to 100 000 a month in that fund
on a set day don't even look at it
so you know you're not trying to like
time the market and be like oh it's down
extra today let me throw more just
consistently on the first of the month
the third of the month whatever just
consistently buying that fund keep the
other half of it in cash because if you
want to buy real estate or a good deal
comes along or something where you need
cash you are suggesting keeps good yes i
would yeah i would uh especially if you
want to buy real estate that leaves you
with enough leftover that gives you some
mobility on that you're going to be
totally fine uh you're going to have six
months worth of your expenses in the
bank
and uh i think that would be fine okay
that's cool but invest half of it i'm
working on that yeah i think for right
now like
what price figure out what price point
you're looking for in real estate and
kind of set aside probably like you know
whatever like 30 40 yeah and then aside
from that i would say don't do like 100k
a month because if you're sitting on
seven figures it could take you like i
mean i'm sure your income is still going
to be contributing to your bank account
so you're literally like i would say
like you should like a weekly basis
maybe like i need to catch up first yeah
yeah like start up a little faster maybe
like 50k a week is what i would say you
could do that honestly it would be
totally fine because at this rate if
you're doing like 100 000 a month i'm
sure you're probably making way more
than that so you're just throwing that
in your bank account and you're gonna be
investing yeah that's the thing too this
cash if you if you're talking about
investing some of the money that you're
making this cash is going gonna stay the
same
it's not gonna you're not gonna be able
to to deplete that money faster it's
gonna keep piling up yeah so you have to
put in more yeah like 50k maybe even 75k
a week or something like that and then
kind of start slowing down as your your
funds start like yeah that's sort of
what i've been doing is like
i've been any time i put something in
it's years around like 10k
it's not enough i've been trying to do
that like every day or twice a day every
time i'm on the app i'm just kind of
slowly getting in
because i'm just scared that i put my
money in let's say all of it or have a
big chunk of it
um the stock market goes down 10
and then that's also the same moment
that this house project you know opens
up and i'm ready like for a down payment
but i'm down and then when that money
goes away i can't let it grow back up
keep keep a good solid 30 you're going
to probably want to take a mortgage out
on that house so you're not going to
need like a huge amount of money right
so like a solid 30
or so for a down payment whatever price
point you're looking for yeah and then
aside from that just uh catch up a
little bit yeah so i got pre-approved
for a mortgage
for 2.75
amazing
that's a really i got two eight seven
five so you're getting a really good
deal yeah and i think and that was a few
months ago
uh for a house i was gonna buy and it
fell through in escrow
um so now i'm looking at another one
that we're working on so i'm wondering
if our interest rate's better than like
three months ago they've gone up a
little bit
they've got they've gone down and then
the last like two weeks has gone up
i wonder if i'm still like locked in for
that i might no usually if if you if you
do a rate lock
most of those rate logs are for 45 to 60
days
sometimes you can get up to 90 days if
you pay extra and you tell them and
writing you on a great lock extension
but even then no no you you would get
you'll still get a good rating you'd get
a good rate but they would have to redo
it on today's interest rates which could
be different which could be different
because you've got to think
significantly but like it's still low
right i'm talking yeah below three i
mean you would be if you if you got two
seven five back then you'd probably be
at two eight to two nine five so we're
talking very good rate yeah okay
so it wasn't a big misstep yeah anything
you're fine you might be able to get the
same rate by the way so i'm just saying
but
rates have gone up a little bit yeah
because i think that's going to be
like the cheapest money yeah what are
you looking in
what do you mean area like to buy the
real estate this this is a lake house
it's uh is it here in california
yeah
yeah it's in bakersfield
it's like a very unique property yeah
yeah trying to get you to move to vegas
vegas okay yes it's in vegas we should
change
field to vegas and no one else tries to
look at this property
yeah yeah it's in vegas everywhere yeah
you should make this vegas
in vegas yeah yeah vegas california hot
market it's in vegas california
you should you should go to vegas at
some point
i'm going to convert you to live in
vegas to live in vegas well you'd save a
lot of money i would love to have my
residency there but then just be here
which is very
hard i think to it's it's hard once
you're already here if you were from
another state and you come in here and
you're not a full-time resident you come
and visit make some videos go back
you're not in their system but the fact
that you've been living here filing tax
returns here you're on the radar now and
they expect you to keep doing that yep
they want their money i want their money
i'm good you know like i like california
that's fair enough you had more time
here
you know like you grew up in santa
monica right so you've been here for
many many years
i'm only been this is only my second
year
so how much importance do you put on
having like a lot of money in 10 20 30
years like is that really important to
you
i think so
and i'm not like you know some like
money hungry person i think it's just
like
it's opportunity it's comfort of living
um
but so yeah i would like to be well off
i think my idea of retirement is to have
enough money being paid either passively
or through investments or something
where i'm making a considerable amount
but not doing anything do you have any
idea of what amount because we could we
could just tell you i'd like to do like
100 a month 100 grand a month just
passively just coming in the door
i mean you're gonna need a lot yeah wait
a hundred grand a month so you would
need about 20 million
okay so it's 20 million maybe then i'll
work until you get there i guess if i'd
say about 20 minutes you can you can
build up to that as long as you have
compound interest index funds working in
your favor you can build up to that it's
very actually maybe more like 30 million
30.
it depends how long you want that to
last you for
probably about 30 million would be a
little bit safer
what do you mean by last week like
saying it that it depletes yes exactly
so if you want just that amount of
passive income that you could spend no
matter what for
basically the rest of your life depends
how long you're gonna live for well if
you had 10 million dollars let's say
and you made what's like the average
stock market return let's say eight
percent well really it's more well more
like six and a half to seven after
inflation say seven percent okay seven
percent
that would be 700 000 a year divided by
12 months that's 58 000
dollars coming in the door yep every
month pretty on average so you know some
months higher than others
uh but if you have enough sitting to
kind of like buffer that for the slow
months but here's the thing you're never
supposed to spend all of it
because you also want it to be growing
at the same time okay so you usually
want to use five percent because
sometimes they have 20-year stock market
returns where they don't do seven
percent or maybe the return is more like
three percent three and a half percent
and then you have some years where it's
15
so the simulation is called the trinity
study and they studied every 20-year
rolling period of the s p 500 ever in
history
and they calculated that on average yes
it's been about seven percent after
inflation but the best years were like
13 and the worst years were i think it
was a half a percent with uh with
inflation it was the worst 20-year
period ever so
they want to be conservative on that and
make sure that over 20 30 years you'll
guarantee to have money left over so
usually for that they recommend like
four percent that's how much you could
actually spend with that it's very
important to be conservative right
investment so four percent is how much
you could realistically spend
without worrying about running out of
money even during a bad stock market
the best case scenario you have a
surplus of money
yeah okay so maybe the better way to do
it is have some
in the stock market that you know chugs
along but then have other things like
businesses that are set up that are
fully automated and self-running with
real estate you wouldn't need 20 million
because you could leverage a little bit
of your money but it's still i mean 20
million is a good amount to shoot for 15
million would be pretty if you have 50
million sitting like not liquid but like
assets or of uh net worth
of net worth yeah but a lot of net worth
doesn't do any work for you like they
invest as in like net worth
like assets minus any debt that you may
owe now it would be 50 million investors
because you if you have 15 million in a
car for instance yes that's not good
right but like 15 million invested yeah
15 million invested okay well how would
it invest like how would owning houses i
guess you would charge and then cash
flow yeah
it would be good because then you would
need less money if because you could
always put a down payment like 20 or so
percent on a house and then
yeah i don't know i mean those are fun
numbers to kind of think about i guess
at the end of the day like retirement i
would love to have myself set up i love
malibu so i'm ultimately going to try to
find a place out there but like buy it
and have it paid off so then my i'm just
paying i guess property tax and
you don't want to pay it off though you
want to have that loan it's a tax
write-off this would be good for you
yeah it's free money i guess that's sort
of free money that's what i mean is like
have okay
so maybe okay i'm learning so you always
want to take loans
anytime you get a loan take a loan
because on a mortgage you're getting
let's say call it even three percent
inflation is probably gonna be about two
percent that means you're only paying
one percent interest on that money
before tax write-offs
that's really cheap versus investing
that money even if you get three percent
somewhere else
four percent you get the profit the
difference so you're making money by
keeping the loan
so could you just get a
loan just to like put in the stock
market and stuff you i mean you could
borrow money here's what i do it's more
dangerous here's what i do i i put as
little down in real estate as possible
so on the vegas place i put 15 down
i got the biggest loan i can so i have
more money left over to invest in the
stock market so i'm not borrowing money
directly to invest in stocks but i'm
putting as little money down in real
estate as possible so i have more money
left over same with this like
i try i don't ever pay extra towards the
principal i just pay the bare minimum
30-year fixed invest a difference put as
little money down as possible yeah if
you wanted to borrow money to put into
the stock market it's it's a little bit
more aggressive but since you are young
i don't think it's like the worst idea
uh you could use a different brokerage
like m1 finance i know yeah but then but
then you get issues with margin calls
right but if that's in the event
it's it's usually prime rates plus like
a little bit sometimes they'll offer
discounts
right now that's m1 finance we'll do two
percent
uh 33 of your portfolio so if you have
if you have 10 million and or i mean i
guess like 12 million invested then
that's of the equivalent of like 15
million it's risky i personally wouldn't
i don't know i think i would be advising
you to do yeah i'm just saying if you
wanted to get more action out of your
money you know your income is very very
strong so
i would just be worried about a margin
call on that just like just in case the
markets drop like 50 something crazy
happens and all of a sudden i'm not
gonna hey we need our loan back it's
very aggressive yeah like okay so i got
pre-approved for the 2.75
for like a two million dollar loan or
something
for a house right but if i had got that
same to let's say put in the stock
market it's not that hard to beat two
and a half you won't you won't get that
loan for the stock you'll get that for
real estate because real estate is is is
a safe investment and no matter what
happens they have that land and they
have the structure to go after so they
use that house as collateral just like
they would use your stocks as collateral
if they gave you a loan on that real
estate is is very safe and that's why
they can give you a 30-year fixed rate
loan at such a low interest rate okay
that makes sense okay with stocks
if it goes down if it goes down they
have the right to say hey you're getting
pretty low going we need some cash right
now to hedge our position real estate
they're not going to do that real estate
that house could drop 90 in value
they're never going to call that loan
yeah that's interesting i guess that
makes
makes sense of like why that would be a
low interest rate so if i were you i'd
put as little down in real estate as
possible invest more that's all you need
to do is just invest more of your money
invest more yeah just get the habit of
doing the the scariest part is just in
the beginning yeah
once you get into it like give it two
months it's not going to seem like a
video yeah exactly yeah yeah as the
graphs kind of start to average
everything
yeah i mean i understand the principle
like you know my best friend went to
wharton
uh
so he you know loves
finances and investing and stuff like
that so like i get the high level stuff
i understand principles and
how it works it's just scary when it's
like i worked so hard and sacrificed
everything to be where i'm at and here's
the chunk of change i have i don't want
to put it in and have it go down 50 yeah
like statistically you have a 66 chance
of uh
doing what's called lump sum investing
we take all the money and just invest it
all at once
66 of the time you'll make more money
doing that than dollar cost averaging
really yeah why is that because on
average the stock market goes up yeah
every year you'll have more green days
than red yeah so more often than not the
sooner you get in the more profitable
it'll be yes that's how it works
mathematically right so you have a 33
chance of hey you put all your money in
and uh bad timing next year is down a
lot
um
but
for odds like that like if you go to a
casino and they say hey 66 of the time
you bet on this you're gonna make money
overall that's pretty smart to take that
bet
and and you wouldn't just be investing
once and ever again realistically what
you do you have a big lump sum you dump
it in the market and you make it a
consistent habit every single month or
every week but then it kind of starts
going to
cost averaging or cost exactly but that
but that's the point of investing right
now you have a big amount that's in your
cash it's what to do with that big
amount yeah so overall it's not going to
make that big of a deal whether you dump
it all in at once or you dollar cost
average because long term you're going
to be investing for the next 20 years
anyway so it's not going to make a huge
difference that makes sense
what helps me is knowing that like i
have full faith in like an understanding
that
on average the stocks just will go up
it's just a matter of time of like how
long it will tell you yeah to make a
profit and if you understand that like
regardless of whatever happens as long
as you hold for a long time you will be
up you know what i mean i'm obviously
not i will never give 100 guarantee but
like i can give the jack guarantee
you know you'll be the napkin guarantee
to have the jack guarantee on something
like that and to have an understanding
and full faith in that it just makes it
a lot easier okay well now that i have
the jack guarantee i'll just dump it all
in lump sum and i'll call you guys
tomorrow if i'm up or down yeah
let me know
what makes it easier for me is that i
know even if the market does go down
you'll keep making money and that's your
chance to reinvest at a lower price so
even though yeah initially you might not
have gotten the best deal
um you'll end up making more money
launch it like i remember when i was
buying into the s p
when it was like 35 and i bought big
chunks at 35 and then it went down to
like 33. i bought bigger chunks at 33
and uh now it's 36 something so yeah i
mean it goes up and down
so i i even when it was at three i was
buying big that's when i did those 50
thousand dollar increments on you for
youtube videos
and i remember hitting three it'd be
like that's that's maybe it's gonna go
down
but it doesn't matter back then people
were worried about it going down the
most important thing is just like
consistent investing yeah that'll do you
well mm-hmm what is the secret to the
stock market that
consistency consistency yeah
uh being diligent not pulling out when
it goes down
never pull out yeah
some sometimes
you never
oh yeah
um
i'm gonna guess
i'm gonna ask two and a half
i'm gonna guess as well i have to think
about it for one second i'm gonna say
i'm gonna say it's probably around
three
point
two
three zero what did google say four or
five
oh i said four or five okay
not no channel
no we the channel we could we could yeah
i don't i don't know that the actual
answer
um
you would basically take the amount of
cash you have in the bank the amount of
cash you have invested the value of the
cars you don't have any debt
whatever the whatever your cash and
asset value are yeah that's that's
that's what it would be
yeah i mean it's probably like
three plus okay yeah so you're closer
jack congrats what do i win
a dollar
i'll give you a dollar thanks man like a
hug
so many dollars we make all these bets
yeah and i always i always lose he wins
and it's always a dollar so this wasn't
even a bet though if it were a bet i
would have placed
i think the way google probably did is
looked at my total channel views and
multiplied it by an average cpm of like
2.75 or three or something like that
yeah that's pretty good that's pretty
pretty accurate that's also like pre-tax
that is true and pre-expense
you know there's expenses and then taxes
are huge
um
so i guess it's like
that's what that would be like they're
really saying half that also minus
expenses or minus expenses first and
then half that right because your videos
could be expensive what's the average
cost you would say for one of your
videos it's pretty low really i don't
spend a lot of money um
i guess for me it's a lot i hear 4 000
lego sets i'm oh wow four grand as much
as airack eric yeah that's true yeah i'd
like to talk to him about that um
but yeah like the four thousand dollars
i just said uh initially for the first
set of these giant legos that we got and
they're so cool they're just literally
giant legos and you can build huge
things and climb on them and stuff
we probably spent around like four grand
you know from china great deal um way
cheaper than if you got something
similar in the us
but then we've i mean we probably made
over
i think phil knows the numbers more but
like over a thousand percent return
maybe two thousand percent return just
an excessive amount like we've done so
many videos that have gone so viral
with that same set of legos
you know so yeah i spent 4 000 on the
first video and that probably broke even
or something and then the next one
then liz filmed a few those went viral
those probably doubled the you know 100
return and then 200 and we hit like one
that hits like 22
million views and that probably
more than 10x is the return alone in
just that one video
you know and then it just keeps going we
just keep using them and so i do a lot
of investments where i like i'll buy
something for like a few thousand
dollars or you know sometimes it's like
a new car or
equipment or cameras but then we'll just
use it all the time
stock market returns that's true
it definitely is actually so i was
talking with uh financial advisors
because i knew i wanted one ended up not
feeling comfortable uh you know so i
feel like i had to kind of do it myself
but they were you know tell them about
like yeah like how much you spend so i
told them to spend this and this is how
much that video would make the big dude
that's more than i could
do in the stock market in a year yeah
you know significantly more and i'm like
so i started kind of thinking more about
it and some of the event investors that
i was interviewing to work with
were kind of saying that like dude your
biggest return is like you need to spend
more on your videos because every time
you invest into one of your videos it
returns so much
more and when i don't spend money on
like new props and things there's less
to film with
or you know less whatever you know and
so it ends up
i just think it's diversifying
it's that you have something to fall
back on should something happen you have
something a little different than
youtube yes and even if you invest 20
it's just 20 of your income just to
invest it spend 80 back on youtube again
you'd be set yeah that's all it takes
yeah i feel like i've just been so hyper
focused on everything
and now i'm finally growing the team
enough
uh to be able to do
to off-board a lot of the tasks that i
normally do every day so i have more
time
in my life to kind of think about the
next thing like hey do i want to buy
like a duplex and rent it out or you
know some kind of real estate which i
find very interesting real estate um
or maybe some other venture that you
know comes comes around but i totally
agree like if youtube goes down how do i
diversify so right now i'm trying to
diversify within the platform so if
youtube goes down i could be like hey
over here on tick tock this is what
happened here's the update people like
i'm not radio silent
uh instagram twitter stuff like that i'm
trying to work on those platforms but
then even outside of all the social
media i feel like i need like something
to
i mean it's fine just start a financial
youtube channel now yeah you could do
some crazy investing like stunts like
i've wanted to do stunts like that where
you give everyone five grand and just
like see see how much money they can
make on robin hood
i think stuff like that would be kind of
fun i just wouldn't do it but uh you
could start doing crazy financial stunts
who could increasingly yeah who can who
can get the most credit cards in 24
hours wins yeah we've done who can make
the most money really yeah that's fun
and it was like 24 hours or some number
of hours we did yeah who made the most
money
i think uh
oh you know it was liz okay yeah how
much did you make so so stove and i i i
don't think i was a part of the
challenge or be teamed up or something
so i was helping him we went down to
like hollywood he was like dancing in a
costume trying to get we made like 20
bucks because fans recognized us we made
like i don't know 40 bucks or something
pretty uh surprising
so all liz did was opened up uh youtube
or instagram and live streamed and made
like i don't know
400 bucks in an hour from live streaming
from donations
and so she just sat there why can't
instagram do that with donations how
much
eight hundred bucks eight hundred bucks
in an hour and like
an hour and a half 800 bucks sitting
there on youtube live streaming or was
it youtube
yeah youtube livestreaming
you donate
oh you donated it yeah well oh yeah yeah
but still like without that then it
would have been 650 bucks you know what
i mean there's like a little push for
that stuff but like yeah i mean we're
out there we drove we had to spend money
on gas we have a costume we're
embarrassing ourselves we got recognized
by fans which is always
tough to navigate when you're like
filming and trying to get caught
and you're trying to take time for
photos
um all kinds of stuff you know like
bumping into people you know it was
crazy that day uh you know we come home
with like
42 bucks and 20 of them i donated to
stone you know what i mean it's so like
i think ryan literally made no money
um
so it's just yeah it's crazy it was very
interesting
and so that's why you know it's hard to
not put a lot of emphasis and focus on
you know youtube and the stuff that we
do because it's very lucrative i can
spend all this trying to like do some
other side gig and well now i'm making
less over here because of the lack of
attention and over here maybe i'm i'm
lucky to make a thousand bucks a month
you know so it's really tough to
diversify when the main is just it's
just like cranking hard yeah and uh you
know may not crank hard forever but
doing the best we kind of keep going you
know how do you not get burnt out
i think i'm probably burned out right
now really yeah
like i'm selling that so how do you how
do you push through do you do it anyway
yeah i kind of do it everybody that's
not the solution yeah and it will catch
up to you so i'm navigating that um so
i'm trying to take so right now i'm
offloading uh i'm bringing on more
people i literally just hired three
people like a few days ago
um
to just start doing less because i need
to have other people like that's kind of
what the burnout is right you're doing
things that you just like are exhausted
to do or you're doing too much or both
do you think you're burnt out because
it's not a challenge anymore to do
something viral to do these crazy stunts
i think a little bit in that vein but
it's more like
i'm
just so tired of all the nitty-gritty
that nobody knows about behind the
scenes i mean you know because you're a
youtuber and stuff
and i'm just so excited to get on to the
next stuff but i have all this like now
that it's grown into such an operation
and stuff so much bag it's so much of a
business to run which i like but it's
hard to be a business and the talent at
the same time but before when we started
it was just
my iphone
and i would go and film it had nothing
else no other responsibilities nothing
to think about and now i have like a
legal team we have a cpa team we have
all these employees we have a house we
have rent we have all these logistics we
have all these channels overhead that's
got to be like 100 000 a month
to run that uh yeah probably
gosh
i mean i would just i would get stressed
so stressed knowing that like every day
you have to bring in a certain amount
maybe i'm making the problem worse
yeah i mean it's gotta be stressful man
every day i would like it i think that's
cool it is a lot of stress like i mean
having the stress is something to keep
you going and at the same time you live
a seems like a very dynamic life you
know what i mean i do a lot of crazy
stuff but what's crazy is i
am dying to just lay on the couch and do
nothing all day so like when i get like
a day off because my job is to do crazy
stuff all the time and be excited and
and uh love that it's so fun
you know what do you like to do outside
of content it's like i'll lay on the
couch and not move for 12 hours two days
in a row and it's still not enough for
before monday i get antsy if i don't do
things for a day i start getting like oh
there's so much stuff i got to do
yeah i mean i feel like that too i'm not
normally like the one that wants to lay
there but you know where i'm at now
being like just exhausted of
uh you know kind of feeling burned out
and stuff
you know otherwise we'll just spend the
whole weekend in malibu liz just bought
a condo
in malibu and it's amazing so we'll go
there on the weekends as often as we can
um and just enjoy like it's kind of a
different vibe out there than uh where
we are it's only 20 minutes but you know
the ocean all that stuff is so nice so
we just try to do that and try to
disconnect
uh you know our minds from work so we
come back we can feel more like
energized and
you know excited to push through all the
tremendous amount of stuff we have to do
in a week yeah i feel at least for me
some of the burnout comes with feeling
like it's repetitive after a while
and uh every now and then when i get a
topic i'm really excited about talking
about it's just
that's when i love it when this new
topic that comes out like i'm so excited
to get my my thoughts about it
and uh
that's when the burnout disappears but
then i feel burnt out it's like oh side
hustles video one quick question yeah
how many hours a week would you say you
work
when we first started we worked
if we weren't sleeping we were working
and that was for
i don't know two years then we had the
great idea of you know what if we took
like weekends off from work so we
started doing that and that was tough to
like not work and like what do we do on
a saturday was weird so we ended up just
kind of working like half anyways why
did you why did you decide to take
weekends off because we realized that we
need like to be more normal like
because it's
you know it's a marathon not a sprint
and we're sprinting and that was great
because we blew up and we established we
felt good
and now we feel like we can kind of be a
little bit more sustainability is the
mindset as opposed to that's how fast we
can run everything
um and then also you know growing the
team and stuff there's other people that
come in they have their own lives and
own places living like girlfriends and
stuff so they like
need to
you know like work life balance is like
a thing i see graham smirking out of the
side of this and so smiling yeah i don't
know you guys are
working every day maybe no we are
it's just funny because like
no taking saturdays off yeah yeah i mean
so even so this day so the day i started
i haven't taken like vacation apart from
like
i took a two and a half day vacation a
couple uh about a month and a half ago
for the first time that was huge for me
um and so i'm dying just to like get out
of the office but even when i'm out in
the couple of vacations i've been on i'm
still having to you know open the laptop
everyone's out having a good time
chilling and stuff and i gotta like
sneak off to my room and work for a few
hours do you like doing that or you
don't like doing it i mean i love what i
do but like
you gotta be able to like have some
times where you just like don't bring
the computer or you know what i mean
like just
check out mentally that's the refresh
that uh combats the burnout i really i
really believe and so
i'm itching for a vacage so i have one
planned but it's also stressful because
i have to make sure i get everything
done and usually when i'm gone i'm
getting phone calls and text messages
there's like all like from all these
different disciplines that i work with
through the finances cpas to the team
to other creators to networking to like
all this stuff and so it's usually
really hard to turn off very very
difficult
and i think that's what i need for like
to come back super fresh mm-hmm
see i find it enjoyable sometimes to be
like always feeling like i'm doing
something productive so it's hard for me
not to do anything productive i'm the
same way that's why i'm in my position
but now that i'm here long enough and i
do think things are feeling a little bit
repetitive and kind of automated in a
way so it's maybe less challenging or
exciting or maybe i'm just more used to
used to it
um i'm feeling more burned out you know
but i i don't know i think
i guess the ebbs and flows i feel like i
need to get out and then come back and
then do that periodically i think it's
just
yeah at least what i need i think but
yeah i mean i love to work and i think
that's part of why you know i am here
because i just
you know found something that i'd love
to work on like and i just obsess on it
and just go and work and i'll just make
any excuse to not go to like a party or
like an event and just work and work and
work and work and work because it's like
awesome i get that
should be ended on what what positive
note do you want to end on jack
um i haven't thought of a positive note
but i have one more quick question would
you consider yourself an introvert or an
extrovert
um
i'm very introverted when it comes to
people i don't know or like parties and
stuff i don't really enjoy them as much
it's over that's a lot for me but within
my own friend group i feel like i'm more
extrovert if that makes sense that makes
sense so i don't know if like a lot of
people are kind of different on
situations i i i would agree with that
yeah i i would consider myself the same
i think like in new groups of people
it's a little weird to i don't want to
like make a big i'll kind of be a
wallflower you know but yeah within my
friend group they would all consider me
like huge extroverts yeah so i don't
know if that's really not answering the
question i don't know i don't wonder if
that's i wonder if it's like everyone
though no it means you're pro i think
that is everyone i mean i don't know
there definitely are certain people that
are just wildly extroverted or
introverted you know the people that
just stay inside all day every single
day i have friends like that and then
yeah that's not like me i like to just
stay at home and not don't do that
sorry
like for me i just like to stay at home
like i don't like if i'm at the grocery
store by myself i'm very intro i'm not
like hey what's up cashier hey what's up
person shopping like bouncing around and
stuff i'm kind of just like don't talk
to me like i'm doing my own thing like
just quiet voices in my head just chat
you know voices in the head they're not
like not schizophrenic i guess but you
know i'm just kind of thinking to myself
just you know living my life just
internally you know
but then with friends it's you know
the opposite
yeah it's very interesting i think you
know to sum it up nice nicely
this has been a nice episode it's been
very nice meeting you uh yeah i've
really enjoyed uh yeah thanks so much
for coming on this is cool you would hit
me up months ago wanting to network talk
business talk youtube weren't able to
make it happen until like a week ago you
gave me a house tour yeah insane house
in bel air how many i don't know how
many square feet is that 20 000 square
feet yeah i think it's 15 000. thousand
nine bet like nine bedrooms something
like that yeah i think it's
ten bedrooms 10 15 bathrooms that is and
only and only you live there right
yeah i mean sort of i have like friends
that stay all the time and but no like
business people like this that is
incredible yeah wow yeah but again we
used to all live in the same house yeah
regardless of size it's the work life
thing that we've really discovered
uh you know having people like go home
to their own spot that they're
responsible for and that stuff versus
like every time i open the fridge like
where's the eggs i bought them last
night you know and then yeah it's it's
the whole thing uh really fascinating
you know what would be fun i just
thought of this because i was starting
to think like who are we gonna have for
the next week's podcast i remember you
and i had talked about somebody and i
can't remember who that was
but what would be fun
is if you gave us a recommendation of
someone to have on the next podcast and
then that person gives us another
recommendation of someone having
really interesting and then every
episode is just a recommendation from
the last person and just see who we meet
i think that might be kind of i don't
know if that's something you're
interested i just thought of that
because i can't
who would you know of anyone that you
think the episode would do well
it would be interesting yeah i mean i
think i have to understand like
what kind of guests do well on your
podcast
like people that are like popular like
famous people or people like people like
finance i've noticed people that like
finance but at the same time obviously
it would be easier if they were popular
if they aren't they it's got to be
something that sets them apart yeah like
super interesting right
joe rogensk
with a hint of finance right okay yeah i
know some people okay there's some guys
on the phase clan that i think would be
really cool okay we can get rug i think
that would be great phase drug would be
cool um i think someone
i think face k if you're familiar with
him
he's uh
really into like finances and investing
like obsessive about it
anybody on that you can that would be
interesting because because usually with
a podcast like i've talked with people
before it's never really just a cold
introduction on a podcast never never
just it so that would be cool to meet
somebody with like yeah haven't met
before if that makes sense
yeah well i think frasier would be
awesome right you know we talk a little
bit about you know he's got all these
businesses and things that he's
investing in also he just are you
familiar with spotter
no it's a very fascinating business
model they'll pay you upfront today for
your future monetization earnings on
your channel
how much do they pay geez like big money
for millions of dollars depending on the
size and
potential future performance of your
cat-back catalog what's what's to say
just don't stop uploading
they will have like upload minimums for
the the term like five years five years
yeah so they'll pay you today yeah cash
a check okay for every video they've
uploaded up until the first of the month
yeah
uh and they'll essentially just
copyright strike all those or claim them
so that that money doesn't go to you it
goes to them for five years and then
they just turn it off
i can't tell you who did that somebody
else i talked to did that i think i'm 99
sure it was the same thing
uh and they sold the rights to all of
their previous videos
for one big a big lump sum that they
then used to reinvest back in the
channel here's the thing it's a
licensing thing they're not selling it
right um that's what i meant i meant to
say yeah well it makes a big difference
i think also with taxes and how you file
it and stuff like that
um
but yeah super interesting i looked into
it um
and i know a lot of people that have
done it end up taking massive seven
eight figure checks
i just want to see how much they'd offer
me i'm so curious
i can give you an idea yeah you could
hit them up and they'll calculate
something i could also like can you give
me an idea i mean
i don't know if you've seen my
see my analytics but you could check
that out
and you could go to the revenue and just
sort by whatever i'm just curious what
they would offer yeah uh it's hard to
say like do your old videos
do well yeah
so like a lot of your top earners
will be
i would say i would say um under 20
videos that will consistently
bring views right right uh it's about 20
or so videos that he's posted in the
past that will consistently do well rank
well yeah i don't know i would say maybe
like how like the tail of your video
yeah 70 of the revenue i would say maybe
maybe
70 of the revenue comes within the last
30 days
and then every 30 of it is just old
videos
it's hard to say because this is
different than what my channel looks
like
yeah yours i've noticed they just
will continually get views because every
video is kind of like a standalone
so mine is news so like some of those
videos that you're clicking on
within a week they're irrelevant
yeah
so that's the biggest part of their
calculation
um
and i have a really good idea how their
model works they have an exponential
decay model that all videos will follow
essentially you know like you post it
like really high and then it just kind
of starts to decay so they have a model
where they figured if they just get
enough youtube videos from enough
different disciplines just like stocks
you can average it and hedge money on
that and put make a business model
without paying it
uh and try to make up some sort of
percent return you know with those risks
some channels will win some will lose
but on average given this mathematical
model they developed they'll make money
so it looks like a lot of your videos
don't have like
huge uh long-term performance you know
like in a month
yeah what is that so you could say it
outlet 18 dollars that video made 18
last month in the last month it's an old
video like you probably uploaded this uh
you know months ago
but yeah 18 bucks whereas like if i had
i'll put one up just to kind of compare
yeah i'll just scroll back similar
amount can you take any sort of
screenshot anything so i can throw it up
and uh uh sure
like here's like a good one so maybe
it's not really apples to apples
but this one is uh and i'll screenshot
this one so this is in the last 28 days
2 000
wow
and this is an old video that i filmed
over
six seven months ago wow and so it's
still doing two thousand dollars a month
it's like a rental property it's good
so it's being a rental property man this
is my favorite one my one of my most uh
profitable videos is how to buy your
first rental property step by step
it has consistently made about twenty
two hundred dollars a month for like
three years now
is that what is that now yeah yeah
that's awesome it's an old video too see
that's
look at that consistency almost a
hundred dollars a day on a video i made
three years ago yeah see that's what i
love about youtube because
you can make these videos man
i haven't looked at these analytics yeah
it doesn't make sense that's crazy like
that's what i think is so cool is you
can make a youtube video and i consider
them as digital assets it's like you
know we have a production company we're
a startup or small but the product that
we produce is are these
free digital assets that we post on
youtube and these assets can continue to
bring in revenue day after day month
after month some of them kind of
exponentially decay but others will just
sit and then just kind of cruise just
like that 100 a day for a year is can i
say that number yeah like 26 000 in a
year but what did you do for that in the
last year
nothing for that particular video i mean
you're keeping the brand going and stuff
but that's just happening kind of like
passive income i think that's amazing
yeah and so that's the kind of content
that i try to produce this stuff that i
think is going to do that and
i think that's also
a great sign of content that also
coincides with being highly entertaining
highly clickable and people love that
video and so he keeps getting watched
it's not like annoying it's not a virus
it's not annoying people people are
enjoying it and they're watching it and
here it is 100 a day for for i don't
know not forever but for a long period
so what do you think they would offer on
uh on my channel
from what i saw it looks like a lot of
your videos really kind of decay right
just i would say there's maybe 30 to 40
videos that bring in the consistent
amount from along well here's the number
that will determine everything
given how much money you're making a
month how many uh like the last
so if you pulled that up in the last
uh 28 days
you made x amount how much you said
170 i think okay so 170 000 how much
of that 170 000 came from videos you
posted in the last month or the last 28
days probably 80 70 of it so 70 came
from those new videos and 30 is your old
so 170 30 so that's 51 000. so that's
almost backwards for me okay mine is
like
whatever i made that month uh
eighty percent is old videos or
like uh 60
60 70 is old videos wow chugging along
so for your channel i i really it's so
hard to say i thought it was gonna be a
little bit more similar and i could kind
of work it that way so i really don't
know can you say how much they offered
you
uh i don't want to say
what if because it's still on the table
i can tell you guys personally i'll blur
it okay
they offered me for my full catalog up
until the start of the month that i was
negotiating you'd have to pay tax on all
that up front wouldn't you
unless you spent it but the thing is the
only the only thing that i pay
is whatever those those videos will
generate the old videos and again they'd
start to decay they don't touch the new
stuff but it seems like you guys get how
that works yeah so i was thinking okay
well what about like
just everything that i posted right uh
20 january 1st 2020 and older like 2019
and older and they offered i think which
seems a little bit better because those
videos already older but then if you
look back they just chug and chug and
chug you can do the math yourself oh
yeah exactly that makes sense so i
didn't do it now that i'm kind of burned
out on the way here i was talking i was
like i don't kind of think about spotter
i don't believe in it because
it pays back so fast
you know it's not like it's a loan and
you pay it back slowly for 30 years no
you take this loan in a way and you
start paying it back the most month one
month too like the way you pay it starts
to decide so they say it's a five year
term it's really not they basically make
most of their investment back at the end
of like year one and a half or two i
believe those investment guys are so
smart they're so calculated they would
not make you an offer that they knew
would not be in their favor in terms of
their risk and reward i mean they might
be off every now and then but i think
they build up enough of a margin in
every person to ensure that they're
making enough money from everybody okay
but in spotter's defense i do agree
they're very smart and whoever is
running their models is leaps and bounds
above the little that i did to try to
crunch my own numbers
however i think this is a really smart
thing for some creators in some
circumstances which i think actually
ends up being a lot is that opportunity
cost of that money today yes is so
amazing regardless of whatever the
technical interest would boil down to
that's true and so i think it is a very
smart fee
very smart for some people but for me
who already has a ton of working capital
that i haven't even invested yet and i
believe in my future success and growth
and i feel from my analytical background
i have
more confidence and control over my
future of stability it didn't make sense
for me yeah that's how i approached it
uh now that i'm burning out i'm kind of
thinking maybe i should take and i'll
cash out and go sit on a beach but you
know i just need a vacation and i'm
going to be back because i do inherently
just love to create crazy content and
yeah massive dreams for the future
so cool that's it's a good point to end
off at what do you think we need like
two hours long i'm sure that offer will
stay there for like like spotter won't
they and they might recalculate yeah and
they could recalculate maybe it's a
little bit lower but you would be i feel
like maybe probably way happier or sorry
way more upset to take it and then
regret it than to take it and then i
just figured like look like what i'm
doing is great it's working i've never
taken a loan or an investment from any
investor before
and uh it's going awesome it's i
couldn't have dreamed to be in the
position i am and have as much success
and uh be doing what i'm doing you know
it's amazing i never even dreamed of it
so why kind of mess with it's not broken
why mess with it yeah you know like if
i'm like in a weird position or
desperate i think that's when it starts
to look a little bit more uh at least
for some in my current position would
look more appetizing i agree but you
know things are great i don't wanna
don't jinx it you know yeah cool i'd say
we wrap up two hours cool
guys oh yes
laughs let me zoom in okay so with that
said you guys thank you so much for
watching i really appreciate it and
carter thank you so much for coming by
you gotta tell them though really quick
before they click out to destroy the
like button for the youtube algorithm
absolutely destroy and don't forget
about the subscribe button if you
haven't already too and the notification
bell we're gonna link our instagrams
down below in the description and don't
forget weeble is now offering
four
free stocks that's right it's crazy they
said their offer uh was ending for three
free stocks and everyone's like oh
they're good they're gonna go down
they just made it better four free
stocks to the end of the month so if you
want four free stocks use that link down
below in the description enjoy let us
know before you get thank you so much
for watching and until next time
see you guys subscribe to carter thank
you
uh it says on the sticker okay so
grab one of these online teamraw.com
yeah
yeah we'll give you a review real quick
yeah let me know what your honest uh
opinion is i don't know if that one's
gonna fit you that's a adult small it's
all good i'm pretty skinny
it might be a camera here i think this
might be a really interesting dude this
is really soft
well let me just try it from this angle
yeah
okay
it's definitely a bit small but you're
kind of squeezing in
is that still filming the triple one
gram yeah okay
so we always have our guests introduce
themselves or introduce the podcast so
you're going to say welcome to the 28th
ever
episode of the iced coffee hour
my name is iced coffee hour uh
how much is the podcast made so far 18
6. 18 000 yeah the podcast is made so
far 18 600
and that's going to be our introduction
18 6
welcome to our 28th ever ever episode of
the iced coffee hour
my name is carter so far the podcast has
made 18 600 dollars so just 18 6. i mean
if you butcher it it's right together
yeah yeah and which camera do i address
that one that one is right on you if you
want to look directly to the audience
that one this is going to be the main
angle for all of us that's going to be
on me you could actually do it in that
one yeah just to start yeah cool so this
is the iced coffee hour episode 28 right
and then 18 6. yep
what's up guys welcome back to the iced
coffee hour i'm carter sharer this is
episode 28 and this podcast has made
eighteen thousand six hundred dollars so
far you could do it again twenty-eighth
ever twenty-eight oh my gosh yeah good
good catch yeah of course
what's up guys welcome to the iced
coffee hour i'm carter cher and this
is take three
you should do the little thing to boop
yeah yeah that'd be funny